[Music]
after completing this lesson you'll be
able to explain the need for business
analytics discuss different types of
business analytics discuss business
analytics case studies and explain the
importance of data science the last two
decades have witnessed extensive
business infrastructure investments due
to this the capability of collecting
data has improved across enterprises
while some businesses continue to
operate in their traditional ways and
other businesses each aspect is now
virtually open to collect data these
aspects are even instrumented for data
collection aspects like supply chain
management marketing campaign
performance manufacturing operations and
workflow procedures are a few examples
simultaneously information is also
available on events like industry news
market trends and movements of
competitors the wide availability of
data has led to increasing interest in
methods to extract useful information
from data science with this data
availability organizations in almost
each industry are focused to exploit
data for their advantage over
competitors earlier organizations used
to employ different teams of analysts
modelers and statisticians for manually
exploring data sets however now the
variety and volume of data has
outstripped the manual analysis capacity
computers have also become powerful and
the networking has become widespread
also algorithms are being developed that
can help connecting various databases to
allow powerful data analysis as a result
of all these phenomena various data
science principles and data mining
techniques are coming into existence
a manager in an organization needs to
take several decisions on the basis of
the problem and alternative courses of
action available to conclude the best
option they need all the information
that is relevant and the criterion to
choose the best option here is a set of
questions that can be important for any
business executive some other
interesting questions that could be
important to business executives are
also listed on the screen let's first
understand what Business Analytics is
it's a scientific process that
transforms data into insight it takes
data from various sources and various
types and convert them into insights
that improve support and automate
decisions the techniques used for this
process are presentation technological
and quantitative in other words it's a
process that uses data for better
decision-making it's used for fact-based
or data-driven decision-making this is
generally considered as more objective
as compared to other decision-making
alternatives business analytics uses
simple tools such as reports and graphs
and also complex tools such as
optimization data mining and simulation
in the graph shown on the screen
we've compared at different data
analytics techniques in terms of
competitive advantage and degree of
complexity prescriptive analytics offers
the most competitive advantage over
other techniques such as descriptive and
predictive however performing
prescriptive analytics is the most
complex data analytical technique we'll
look into details of each of these
techniques in the subsequent screens
let's now talk about the features of a
business analytics or BA the first
important feature is the support to
various methodologies these include
concepts from applied probability
applied mathematics applied statistics
and computer science since it's used by
organizations that are committed to
data-driven decision-making the data
produced helps in gaining meaningful
insights into better business planning
and business performance the next
important feature is decision support
systems in data-driven companies data is
treated as a corporate asset successful
analytics is dependent upon the quality
of data and analysts who know the
business and technologies solutions are
primarily used as decision support
systems or as their components the
solutions help executives sell people
and other organizational leaders to make
business decisions another important
feature of business analytics is
business continuity support as business
analytics supports essential business
functions and also supports tactical
decision making with respect to
unforeseen events it also aids in
functions such as hiring reducing
attrition improving retention performing
staff deployment and deciding strategy
in many cases decision making is
automated for supporting responses in
real time
this lesson will help you understand the
concepts related to different types of
business analytics such as descriptive
analytics predictive analytics
prescriptive analytics supply chain
analytics healthcare analytics marketing
analytics given resource analytics and
web analytics descriptive analytics
analyzes the past events and predicts
the approach of future it analyzes the
past performance by mining the past data
and look for the reasons why past
failures or successes happen almost all
management reporting such as finance
operations marketing and sales uses this
analytics the related models quantified
data relationships in a manner that is
generally used for the classification of
customers and prospects into various
groups for instance these models can be
used to classify customers on the basis
of their preferences and life stages
they can be used to create further
models that can make predictions and can
stimulate various individualized agents
some of the data techniques used by this
analytics includes reports data mining
techniques descriptive statistics data
queries data dashboards and basic
what-if spreadsheet models
addictive analytics converts data into
actionable and usable information it
determines the possible future outcome
of an event or the possibility of a
situation it includes various
statistical techniques from machine
learning data mining modeling and game
theory and include techniques that use
models created from past data to predict
the future or determine the impact of
one variable on another when it comes to
businesses these models use the patterns
found in transactional and historical
data for identifying opportunities and
risks they allow risk assessments by
capturing relationships between various
factors the three basic cornerstones of
this analytics are predictive modeling
decision analysis and optimization and
transaction profiling an example to use
this analytics can be to optimize
customer relationship management systems
some other examples include a company
that can create a mathematical model for
predicting the future sales by using
past data on product sales and the food
manufacturing company that can estimate
the measurement and quality of unit
sales by using the point-of-sale scanner
data from retail outlets
a few other examples include an
organization that can predict the market
share of a new product by using the
survey data and past purchase behavior
using predictive analytics these
organizations can analyze the spending
use and behavior of customers this leads
to effective cross sales and high
profitability an organization must
employ an experts team or data
scientists to find and access the
appropriate data this team can work with
business leaders for designing business
strategies by using predictive analytics
techniques such as time series analysis
linear regression data mining techniques
and simulation or risk analysis
script of analytics uses mathematical
scientists machine learning business
rules and big data for making decisions
and suggesting decision options it
specifies the best course of action for
a business activity in the form of the
output of a prescriptive model it goes
beyond predicting the outcomes of future
and also suggests the action to benefit
from the predictions it anticipates the
reason of an incident and not just what
in when it will happen it can also
suggest decision options on the method
to take the benefit of a future
opportunity or to mitigate a risk of the
future the models used in this analytics
are called optimization models and
combines various business rules
mathematical models and data the input
can be internal data external data and
various other sources here are some
example industries in which this
analytics is used the airline industry
can benefit by using revenue management
models and past purchasing data as
inputs to get the best pricing strategy
across all flights
similarly the finance industry can use
portfolio models that utilize historical
investment return data to decide the mix
of investments
examples of prescriptive analytics our
supply network design models in
operations and price markdown models in
retailing in operations supply network
design models provide cost minimizing
plant and distribution center locations
retailing use price markdown models that
provide the timing of discount offers
and revenue acts amaizing discount
levels one of the traditional analytics
applications was in supply chain
management and logistics it's used at
the core of companies like FedEx and UPS
it's used for efficient delivery and
optimal sorting of goods it's also used
for vehicle and staff scheduling vehicle
routing better inventory and processing
control and efficient supply chains
analytic tool used in this area span the
complete analytics spectrum for instance
it's been used by the women's apparel
manufacturer Bernard Klaus in the
company used a descriptive analytics for
presenting its supply chain status to
its managers another example is ConAgra
Foods packaged foods company which use
prescriptive and predictive analytics
for planning its capacity utilization
better by including the inherent
uncertainty in commodities pricing the
company received 100% return on their
investment in analytics in less than
three months
analytics and healthcare is used to
simultaneously control cost and provide
more effective treatment to patients
predictive prescriptive and descriptive
analytics are used to improve staff
patient and facility scheduling they're
also used to control inventory
purchasing and patient flow for instance
as per the McKinsey Global Institute or
MDI
and McKinsey and company for Team study
by better utilizing analytics the United
States healthcare system could save more
than 300 billion each year which is
equivalent to the complete gross
domestic product of countries such as
Singapore Finland and Ireland
marketing is one of the expanding areas
to apply analytics a better
understanding of customer behavior by
using data generated from social media
and scanner data leads to several
advantages such as better use of
advertising budgets effective pricing
strategies improved demand forecasting
that our product line management an
increased customer satisfaction and
loyalty one of the example is automobile
manufacturer chrysler ting with JD Power
and Associates they developed predictive
models for supporting their pricing
decisions for automobiles as they helped
Chrysler to better understand the
ramifications of proposed pricing
structures the model generated in
estimated annual savings of 500 million
dollars
the use of analytics in the human
resources area is relatively new with
the use of analytics the HR function
ensures that the organization employs
the required skill sets to meet its
needs hires the highest quality talent
provides an employee retention
environment and achieves its
organizational diversity objectives
Sears Holding Corporation or SH C is an
example in this area it created an HR
analytics team inside its corporate HR
function that use descriptive and
predictive analytics to support employee
hiring and attracting and influencing
retention
web analytics is the analysis of online
activity such as visiting websites and
social media sites like LinkedIn on
Facebook it has huge implications for
promoting and selling products and
services through the internet some
points to remember are that leading
companies use descriptive and advanced
analytics to data collected in online
experiments for determining the best way
for configuring websites position ads
and using social networks to promote
products and services online
experimentation includes exposing
various subgroups to various website
versions and tracking the results these
experiments proved to be ineffective as
they allow the company to use the trial
and error method and statistically
determining what makes a difference in
their website traffic in sales
why is decision-making in any business
very important the goal of business
decision-making is to high revenue low
costs and low expenses it's supported by
business analytics in various ways such
as for increasing revenue while keeping
selling expenses the same business
analytics suggest changes in the
Salesforce deployment it can also be
used if a company's employees are
leaving voluntarily for higher paying
jobs and there are high onboarding costs
in such cases business analytics
recommends raises that can help retain
existing employees
business intelligence or bi refers to
reporting and analytics tools
traditionally used for determining
historical data trends these techniques
and tools are used to transform raw data
into useful information for the purpose
of business analysis it includes a set
of processes methodologies technologies
and architectures that uses the output
of the information management processes
the technologies can handle large
amounts of unstructured data for
identifying developing and otherwise
creating new strategic business
opportunities bi enables queries by
which users can get results by asking
data related questions it allows easy
data interpretation of high amounts of
data while implementing an effective
strategy based on insights that can help
a business gain a competitive advantage
bi includes tools that are designed to
present the results of analytics in an
understandable format they provide
historical current and predictive views
of business operations some functions
include online analytical processing
process mining prescriptive analytics
text mining business performance
management and benchmarking
data science includes processes
principles and methods to understand
phenomena through automated data
analysis it allows data-driven decision
making or DDD which determines the
productivity of an organization DDD is
the practice of basing decisions on data
analysis instead of just intuition
organizations get involved in DDD to
lesser or greater degrees which decides
the productivity of the organization's
the given image shows how data science
interacts with the outer world
let's now talk about the importance of
data science you can consider data
science a business asset that is about
data investment an understanding of its
fundamental concepts is required for
data scientists and anyone working with
data scientists employing data
scientists investing in data heavy
ventures or directing an analytics
application in an organization DDD and
Big Data technologies improve business
performance substantially data science
supports DDD and at times performs such
decision-making automatically
with respect to data science the key
strategic assets are data and the
ability to extract useful information
from data many businesses use data
analytics to get value from the existing
data and to generally consider if the
business has the right analytical talent
incorrect data and unsuitable data
science talent results in issues such as
poor decisions
big data typically refers to datasets
that are too large for traditional data
processing systems its technologies are
considered as a popular platform for
data analytics and data exploration and
used to implement data mining techniques
and data processing these technologies
are also used to process data in support
of the data mining techniques and other
data science activities nowadays
companies that employ Big Data
technologies have started asking what
can I now do that I couldn't do before
or do better than I could do before
therefore it's possible the golden era
of data science
different types of analytical tools
available are listed on the screen
these are open source software have
object-oriented design and can be linked
with general programming platforms they
also offer extensibility and various
other features let's summarize the
topics covered in this lesson business
analytics is a scientific process that
transforms data into insight descriptive
analytics includes techniques that
explain what has happened in the past
predictive analytics includes techniques
that predict the future
by using models created from past data
or determine the impact of one variable
on another prescriptive analytics the
final phase of business analytics
specifies the best course of action for
a business activity in the form of the
output of a prescriptive model it
utilizes the techniques of descriptive
and predictive analytics to anticipate
the future of a business and to suggest
optimal decision options on the basis of
such predictions analytics tools are
used in logistics and supply chain
management and many companies hey want
to become an expert in Big Data then
subscribe to the simply learned Channel
and click here to watch more such videos
sinnard up and get certified in Big Data
click here